so it was late last night 11 54 p.m
eastern time the president tweeted a
response to the roger goodell video from
friday night could it be even remotely
possible that in roger goodell's rather
interesting statement of peace and
reconciliation he was intimating that it
would now be okay for the players to
kneel or not to stand for the national
anthem thereby disrespecting our country
and our
flag the rather interesting statement i
don't understand the intent there that
there's is there sarcasm is i i don't
know but the bottom line is this we have
a clear reiteration from the president
of that belief that was held by drew
brees as of last wednesday but abandoned
by friday night that any type of
conscientious protest
during the national anthem by taking a
knee taking a seat doing anything other
than standing in attention with hand on
heart or salute is inherently
disrespectful to the country and the
flag and the military and whatever other
laundry list you want to add to that
instead of understanding that this is
something that is done as an exercise of
freedom of that deliberate intention of
making people aware of a specific
problem the message that colin
kaepernick was trying to send in 2016.
so if the president is going to say
that kneeling equals disrespect there's
going to be a segment of the country
roughly 30 percent that will agree with
him that will fall in line with that
that's what we've lived the last five
years
and it's on
we're right back to where we were
in
2016 and into 2017 and that whole that
the the comment that was made at the at
the rally in alabama in september of
2017 that really turned this into a
major issue they reached what i thought
was a delicate truce in 2018 chris there
was an issue with a new trade deal in
canada there was something the nfl
wanted the administration got it roger
goodell thanked the president publicly
the president acknowledged that and they
reached that kind of that kind of a
cease-fire right well it's it's over
it's over it's back now because i
interpret what happened last week as
meaning players can and will kneel
during the anthem this year and the
president who is up for reelection if
you haven't heard in november will be
doing everything he can to turn this
into an issue that gets his base
sufficiently motivated to show up at the
polls and vote for him it's that simple
it's that clear and that's what's coming
for the nfl over the next five months
yeah it seems that way i mean you're you
know you're right when you say it's on
it does it seems like it's on
you know the nfl players aren't going to
back down this time though they don't
care they don't and you know again their
argument they're going to be able to
make is well hey mr president if you
listened a little bit more clearly the
first time around we wouldn't be in this
predicament in round two also what's
different this time around what you said
to start the show mike you know the the
court of public opinion has swayed a
little bit here there's no doubt do we
still have the detractors from white
america trying to say that racism isn't
a problem in our country still sure
certainly definitely no doubt about it
we're never going to get rid of all of
them but i do think we've seen more eyes
opened in the last 10 days to two weeks
about this subject and the injustices
and how real they are okay and you know
again i i you know i haven't been a big
fan of the leadership we've gotten out
of mr trump the president to this point
either right and and i really applaud
drew brees for standing up to him in
this moment but yeah i don't know where
it goes from right now right now we're
going to have a little bit of a an issue
and it's going to be controversial
there's no doubt about it but i think
americans see this issue in a different
light than they did four years ago
the president told cowboys owner jerry
jones at some point during the initial
skirmish between the league and the
president over the anthem that this is a
winning issue for me he liked it he knew
that it was something he could just keep
banging that drum bang that drum tweet
out you must stand for the flag you must
respect the flag that that is going to
be something that will get his people
excited and angry and ultimately
motivated to show up and vote that's
what this is all about that's what
politics ultimately boils down to folks
finding ways to get the people who are
inclined to support you to show up on
that first tuesday in november and put
your name
on the ballot or press the button or do
whatever it is in whatever state where
you vote they want you to show up and
vote for them and then further down the
ballot for candidates of like political
persuasion that's all it is and this is
a very easy topic for the president and
i was surprised he backed off of it in
2018 and my guess is that there were
some some backroom dealings that were
done to get him to leave the nfl alone
and that's over now that's that's done
between goodell and breeze on friday
night the line has been drawn in the
sand and it's obvious the nfl at least
from roger goodell and drew brees
perspective is not going to back down
here the question is
how many owners
are going to sign on for this how many
owners especially those who have
supported the president with major
donations whether to the campaign or to
the inauguration fund from early 2017.
how many of those owners who don't want
this fight who don't want to worry about
ratings dropping again who don't want to
worry about season ticket holders
canceling assuming that season ticket
holders can even show up this year how
many of those owners now are going to
push back
internally
with roger goodell and with other owners
who are saying we don't care now is the
time to stand up for what's right and
we're with our players and if that means
we're against the president on this
issue then so be it because we're with
our players well yeah i think that's it
mike i mean just like you talked about
with colin kaepernick and you were right
in so many ways the last segment right
you know it's time to do what's right
there's there's no more like oh we're
gonna play both sides no we've hit a a
period here in human history not just
america i mean the protests are going on
all across the world right now because
of these injustices and i think that
this is the first time that the nfl and
this type of fight yeah it might not be
pretty
but i think it's going to have the
backing of the majority of the public
here too i do and and i think that's
really going to be one of the big the
big things to turn this let alone what
roger goodell said what you just said
this league is not a league unless we
have african american football players
they're the stars of our league there's
no doubt about it they're the meat and
potatoes of our league and we know
they're passionate and they're knee-deep
in this fight which they should be and
i we as white americans i believe owe it
to them to get right into this fight
knee deep too and start fighting them
with them and i think a lot of these
smarter people running the nfl have
realized that and i think the time has
come and we're going to have to make a
stand to the president and some of that
part of his his base you know i mean our
you know the the player side would argue
that he's been very disrespectful with
the flag in a lot of ways himself too so
this street goes both ways you can't
just call it a you know one way
uh this is that one day per year where i
am reminded of the reality that we are
all here on this planet for a finite
period of time and the question we all
have to ask ourselves is how do we want
to be remembered
how how how do we want our families to
remember us our kids to remember us
and and this is an issue where
to me it's as clear as it can be and i
know that that given that just
everything that's happening and the hard
feelings and the strong feelings and the
fact for a lot of people they just don't
want i think this boils down to the
reality chris that people just don't
want
their their lives to be further burdened
with something else
to worry about life is hard enough in
america today if you haven't noticed
because of the pandemic and it's hard
enough to hold it together for your
families folks i get that and i know
it's hard to take whatever free time you
do have and to be constantly revisiting
your own experiences your own mind your
own soul your own views on things and
just have it feel like it's all been
turned upside down by the events of the
last two weeks i get it i get it but for
everyone especially people in positions
of power and influence the question
becomes how do you want to be remembered
on this issue do you want to be
remembered for doing the right thing or
do you want to be remembered for doing
the expedient thing the thing that
allowed you to have a 10
revenue increase this year instead of 4
well
and and i think that's what i'm trying
to impress upon everybody now is the
moment to do the right thing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports